how does one who is single and has been
single for a while and has been very
good at being single for a while
how does that person who is now
especially and and this is going to
sound like I'm talking about you but I'm
talking about a lot of friends right now
that we have that are late 30s early 40s
they don't need to get married they're
doing great they're making money but
they're getting to a point where they're
sitting there saying I wouldn't mind
having a kid right I wouldn't mind
having a family honestly I'm so sick of
it the number that used to matter when
you would brag to your friends you know
the number like oh I've been with this
many other Notch count no one cares
anymore like who cares about what the
numbers anymore at this point it
mattered in 20s it doesn't matter in
your 40s what what challenges is that 40
Year Old Mill going to face to go from
being fully free for many many years to
all of a sudden decide to commit to one
person and build a family what challenge
is that guy going to face it's I I have
my friend John from Modern Life dating
is probably a pretty good example of
this as well as once you get to that
point once you get to like 36 37 years
old and let's just say you've been on
your game you have maximized your
potential uh as you know your value as a
guy uh there will come a point where you
have
um let's just say solve the mystery of
women you've solved the mystery of money
you've solved the mystery of whatever it
is that sort of has been your obsession
for as long as it has been and now it
seems kind of like uh like old old news
to you and what's the next challenge
what's what's next what's the next goal
and I I have said this as well is that I
think that again like men and women are
innate compliments we're better together
than we are apart and I think that at
some stage men are going to say you know
what I would rather have the quality
than the quantity but those guys don't
get to that stage unless they kind of go
through the idea that they either had
the call the quantity or that they could
have had the quantity
um most men like I said when the average
age of marriage for men is uh the ones
that are getting married is like 29
years old that also coincides right at
that Epiphany phase that I was just
talking to you guys about so when that
guy's 29 years old and he's not quite
reached his Peak potential when he gets
to 36 37 years old and he's already
committed to a woman who was like 20
years you know 28 years old back in the
day he might be thinking well damn I
didn't know I was going to be this hot I
didn't know I was going to have this
much money I didn't know I was going to
be at this status and that's why you get
things like the midlife crisis at that
point and so it's not so much a midlife
crisis as it is oh damn I now realize my
own potential and uh now I'm having
second thoughts or now I'm like you know
I'm I'm gonna go buy a sports car to
sort of relive my my youth that's really
sort of where that comes from but when
those guys are are not committed and and
they get to 230 so that's one scenario
the other scenario is the one you just
said is when they get to be 36 37 years
old maybe 38 years old pushing 40 and
they go you know what I I'm done with
this I really kind of want to want to
log out and I want to you know have
something that's a little more permanent
they'll ask me they'll say Rollo I don't
want to get with one of these girls on
fresh and fit who's like 18 22 years old
because they seem kind of really you
know flighty and and not somebody you
want to start something with but also I
don't want to get with a woman who's
sort of like used up and is uh really
kind of full of herself an alpha female
at 33 years old who has sort of built
herself into that archetype
how do I solve my problem I tell them
you say you know you have to look for
certain you have to be a good judge of
character you've got to be able to if
you're reading my books if you if you if
you're red pillow where if you're a good
judge of character if you maximize your
potential I've always said that the The
Sweet Spot is kind of somewhere between
like say 25 and 27 years old and looking
for a woman who uh who understands like
what her sexual market value is versus
what her personal value is and those
women do exist and I want to point that
out it's not like I think a lot of
people think that I think all women are
the same no or all men are the same no
I'm not saying that there are
commonalities that are that are
characteristic of men and women we have
our sort of innate differences of course
but when you're talking to like women in
different cultures in different
religions in different countries
wherever those cultures are going to be
vastly different than they are here in
the United States because maybe they
haven't sort of been corrupted with like
you know feminism or whatever to that
point so you're looking at women in life
like Muslim like Muslim majority
countries you're looking at Latin Latin
countries those those women are going to
be of a different kind of like
understanding of like well going forward
this is what I'm what I'm going to be
about so there's a lot of variables that
get there so so so at that very this is
what I took from wood and and I'm
curious what your follow-up is going to
be there is I'll turn it over to you
right after this so to me based on what
you just said this is what I took away
from it culture and a tradition nation
is something you ought to value at that
age you ought to look for that is that
kind of what you're saying that you
should at least have a good
understanding of what how that person
whether male or female came to their
certainly their belief sets but also uh
what is it that has acculturated them
into the personalities that they have so
definitely you know there's
environmental influences there's natural
innate influences and then there's
cultural influences as well what do you
think about that you know you know split
your h plus seven
yeah plus seven yeah well let me tell
you something about like age
appropriateness it only works in the
female sense it doesn't work in the male
sense because we live in a gynocentric
social order that says well you know uh
was it uh Keanu Reeves they when he was
dating his his uh I think she was like
46 and he's like my age like 53 or 54
years old and the woman he was dating at
the time looks like his mother looks
like he's like she's got gray hair and
everything and women were just like yeah
he's dating somebody that's uh that's
age-appropriate you look at Leonardo
DiCaprio none of his girlfriends have
been older than 25 years old and as soon
as they get to 26 he Cycles them out and
gets another 20 years expired can of
milk exactly and so that's and and you
can there are actually online sites that
like track his his girlfriend's ages
across the so who's doing it right who
is Leo doing it right or is is uh is
Kiana doing it right is Keanu still with
the lady I don't I don't know but that
was yeah that's the that's the gal right
there I believe Hugh Jackman is yeah a
Hugh Jackman Hugh Jackman is my age he's
53 and his wife is 66 years old what's
uh Jason Jason Momoa just broke up with
uh Lisa Bonet who is 54 and I believe
he's 41 or 42. well Lisa Monet had it
going on for a while and she was with
Lenny Kravitz
macron uh the PM of France is it
president prime minister whatever his
wife is like 20 years older than him but
we only have we only have we only have a
problem with age appropriateness when it
is a man that is dating uh too too young
so what's too young half plus seven is
it ten years if you look at the
difference between say
um like Lisa Bonet and and Jason Momo
what's that about a 10-year difference
13 years yeah well 13 years so if you
got a guy who's 33 and he's dating a 20
year old girl technically it's illegal
you could go ahead and do that but we go
oh my gosh he's robbing the cradle right
but if it's the other way around oh
she's a cougar think about it I just
think is it going to work you know you
may you may be like oh that's cool you
know he's getting more an Ashton Kutcher
yeah that was a that was a success story
showed up so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]